so sometimes you want to say to people
shut your mouth shut your mouth sh you
just want to go you know you get me
angry sometimes might remember he stood
up he was crying he was shaking how dare
you emotional we had to change the
subject we had to buy him food we had to
calm him
down brothers and sisters and friends
and welcome to the most realest podcast
in the D the three
Muslims it's good to have you back man
last time we did this was what two years
ago for the
opportunity I think it was two years ago
I think my understanding of time has I
think diminished over the years so
sometimes I don't know what day it is so
wow you know when you travel a lot time
and space is a bit blurred yeah so
there's nothing deep in that don't worry
but generally speaking if you told me
what I did a year ago I'm like what who
when why my memory is not that good in
actual fact that's maybe why I'm still
married because uh Mike Tyson once said
the secret to a good marriage is a bad
bad
memory what that was me I said that ah
me really I forgot you know so that help
it helps alhamdulillah alhamdulillah for
Islam we got two reverts in this room
and two born Muslims got a Puerto Rican
over there Al on know we got Greek are
you 100% Greek yes so my mom is Greek
suor so ethnically she's Greek and my
dad is from Greece and he's
Greek we got Palestinian in the
house free palestin in the chat and we
got racially ambiguous Bengali I don't
understand why people don't think I'm
Bengali did you think it was Bengali or
no no what did you think it was I don't
know but if you said benoli probably
that wouldn't be the first thing that
I'm going to be thinking about I mean
listen like myself I'm sure there's many
people watching at home they've seen you
in the Lawrence crowd debate this was
like their first exposure to 10 years
ago 10 years ago maybe even more than
that right and this was my first
experience watching an intellectual
altic in the dawa growing up there was
always this preconceived notion that
it's you're either going to be an
intellectual and an atheist or you're
going to be a Muslim and you're going to
be a little bit out of touch with
reality objective science and all that
so when I got to the understanding that
you can actually have both it's not
mutually exclusive you can be a proper
Muslim and actually be closer to truth
and understanding science than I ever
imagined it blew my mind bro so why
don't you go into that and how you've
changed since you started giving that
debate so that's a very good question
obviously hopefully not obviously but
hopefully I'm not the same person I was
10 years ago if that is the case then
something is seriously wrong so from an
academic point of view it was after that
debate I started to take Academia
seriously so I did a postgraduate
certificate in philosophy I did a
master's in philosophy I did a MERS in
research and philosophy then I'm I'm
finishing off my PhD which is to do with
the Quran and philosophy of science and
hermeneutics and the verses pertaining
to
Nature so from that point of view
hopefully I've changed and maybe
developed optimized my narrative and my
arguments and throughout that period i
think I became a little bit more
islamically grounded from the point of
view of understanding the Islamic world
view understanding the role of Islamic
psychology what does it mean to be a
human being you know we have an an
intellect but is that enough no because
the kind of psychological schema if
you're like of the human being is that
we're not just an we're not an intellect
rather we have a and the does it waivers
it has fit tribulations like destructive
doubts Shah blame with the
desires and it has diseases like
arrogance self amazement ostentation
hassad blameworthy jealousy and the
according to the majority of the the
scholars the is a function of the the so
if you're addressing the yeah if you're
addressing the in abstraction but your
is wavering it
does it's diseased
and it has F then if you're not
addressing the vessel that is carrying
the if you want to use that terminology
then no matter what you give the you
ain't going nowhere yeah it's just
abstract it's just it's not you're not
dealing with the human and obviously you
have the F the innate disposition you
have the the soul the NS and all of
these things that Dynamic into playay so
that made me appreciate Islam and truth
and the pursuit of Truth in a different
way because I think at that time maybe
the understanding of the of my da was
that it's about abstract rational
arguments and I've moved away from that
in in a more balanced sense I hope and
going into Western Academia has helped
as well because you see that even the
academic space it has its own
assumptions and presuppositions that can
be challenged but sometimes they take
them for granted and so on and so forth
so that helped me understand maybe what
I would call a more normative Orthodox
understand understanding of Da which is
look you know we have an innate
disposition it can get clouded so as
Allah says in Chapter 30: 30 to adhere
to the F to the innate normative
original disposition that Allah created
us and we have the Hadith in sah Muslim
where the Prophet sallallah alai
wasallam said that every child is born
in that state that F the innate
normative disposition and the Hadith
continues and basically explains that
it's the parents of the child that
changes the child that moves them away
from that natural state so we have this
F and then as I said before there's a
dynamic interplay with the and the and
the and the and the and all of these
things and the F if you like gets
clouded so you
know the older Hamza I would say is the
type of person that would maybe focus on
one way of unCloud the F and thinking
that is the only way like abstract
rational arguments God's existence proof
of Quran which is great and we should
use it but that is not the only way to
unCloud someone's F and this is
important because if you're going to
give da who are you giving da to your da
is an invitation but to who you're
inviting people to Allah but you're
inviting people to Allah so who is the
person and sometimes we miss that in the
daa dynamic if you like because
fine in order to give da you have to
know who Allah is of course you have to
invite with hikma with wisdom with h
preach with with with Excellence
goodness mercy and so on and so
forth but you're doing that to a human
being if you assume the human being is
only an AK an intellect an abstract
intellect then you're not going to be
engaging with the human being in the
right way you might get a success
because the abstract rational arguments
was the thing that was required to
unCloud the F but for many other humans
it's other things or it's a combination
of the rational arguments and the
emotive arguments and maybe the more
spiritual arguments talking about
Allah's names and attributes why he's
worthy of worship so there are different
ways to unCloud our F in order for the F
to continue its Journey towards the
truth so you could see the f as a
vehicle that's driving toward
destination h destination truth but but
the vehicle its windscreen is clouded so
our job is to unCloud the fitra to allow
it to continue to continue its
destination to find the truth but the
problem here is in my order da it was ah
the only way to unCloud the F unCloud
this wind screen if you like for the F
the the vehicle of the F to continue
towards the truth is using rational
arguments which is totally false
especially when we look at the way the
sahaba became Muslim we look at how
Muslims throughout the ages became
Muslim and just understanding Islamic
psychology because Allah created the
human being Allah knows the human being
better than the human being knows the
human being and we even know this with
cognitive science today anyway because
in cognitive science there's an
understanding that you may think you're
rational but that rationality or that
conviction is actually driven by
psychological and emotive forces so what
am I saying in all of this mumbo jumbo
I'm basically
saying hopefully an understanding of the
Islamic world view understanding of the
F understanding of Islamic psychology in
the context of DA has optimized my da to
the degree that it's
hopefully giving me the potential I'm
not saying I am it yeah giving me the
potential to be more intellectually
spiritually mature to assess someone and
say fine they may have an intellectual
argument but I know the human being is
not just an abstract it's not just an
abstract intellect he has a a it could
be clouded he has a he has a and he may
be disease or whatever they maybe and I
need to now assess what he really needs
not what he wants because sometimes you
know the Dua people who who share Islam
we give people what they want we don't
give them what they need and the Art of
Da is to give them what they need not
what they want and that's and that means
that you have to be what now you have to
be dedicated to the well-being love for
your brother what you love for yourself
another Hadith love for L love for
Humanity where you love for yourself
even the Hadith on brotherhood it
expands to non-muslims not from the
point of view that we love of them so we
don't have a love of the kufur or of the
person who is in a way of being that is
rejecting Allah but we love for them and
Islam has a very powerful understanding
of love there's a difference between
loving of and loving for we love for
everybody we want everyone to have
guidance and goodness yeah and and now
we comments on this the famous classical
scholar and he says the Hadith that
refers to love for your brother where
you love for yourself it could mean
non-muslims from the point of view that
you want goodness and guidance for them
so the art of Da is if you want goodness
and guidance for them and it's not just
about you being right or them being
wrong you imposing them or them not
imposing on you you looking good them
looking bad if it's not about that ego
stuff it's about their goodness and
guidance then you're going to be asking
the question what is the right way of
engaging with this human being and you
may understand that but actually they've
asked me a question about causality and
God's existence
but from my experience and from me being
authentic with them and wanting best for
them I understand something else is
going on so I'm not going to address
this I'm going to give them what they
need not what they want for example and
I've mentioned this many
times there was a Pakistani atheist a
university came up to me and he asked me
about a particular question he said oh
Hamza your argument for God's existence
doesn't make sense because causality
doesn't make sense outside of the
Universe I could have went into a kind
of Canan response I could have said to
him that you think quality is basically
derived from experience but it's
actually the other way around you need
the nature of the causal link or an
understanding of quality in order to
understand experiences in the first
place blah blah blah blah blah pointless
though so due to maybe experience maybe
having this more what I call normative
understanding about the human being and
da and being committed to the guy I
basically asked him a question I said
what do you mean by qual to long story
short he didn't know because I got him
to understand that even in Western
metaphysics they don't understand the
nature of the C link there's no there is
no consensus on this issue so I said to
him isn't it very interesting that
you've now said that you don't know what
causality
means but you're using it in a sentence
to deny Allah and it's a key word what's
going on so I was more brotherly to him
we had we walked we sat down you know
what he said at the end I I came from a
secular background my parents were
secular I did not know how to connect
with Allah subhah wa ta'ala so from Kali
to connection
but sometimes if we don't have the right
approach in the da we would have been
debating with him into an
app another story is there was this guy
who was doing the algorithm for Facebook
he was denying Allah very soft kind of
Meek guy you know he's like a nice guy
harmless yeah the way he speaks the way
he comes
across and in the beginning he was
talking about artificial intelligence
and Consciousness and that's my thing we
were talking about it we had a bit of a
disagreement I think I W the debate or
the discussion um but that was pointless
the main thing was he felt that
artificial intelligence could be fully
human in terms of fully human conscious
would have human consciousness in in the
fullest
sense and I disagreed with him and I
gave him my response but then to cut
long story short I said to him in the
conversation why are you denying Islam
why you denying Allah and he says Allah
has humanlike names and attributes
that's why and gave him the
101 there is nothing like Allah subhah
waala Allah's names and attributes are
maxing perfect they're Transcendent they
are to the highest degree possible we
don't not compare them with with with
creation we don't humanize God's names
and attributes and we don't
deify creation and so on and so forth
gave him the basics right but then I
understood there was a contradiction in
the beginning he was okay for the AI
that is a creat
of the the human so the the human is a
Creator in this sense of the AI and the
AI to share the same attribute of being
fully conscious as it's created the
human but in the context of Allah we
disagree with it but in the context of
Allah he was unhappy with that so that
was a logical contradiction in his
discourse and when I noticed that I'm
like okay he doesn't have rational
arguments against Islam it's veiling
something else so I subtly spoke about
my relation with my father and how I
fixed it and when you have traumatic
experience or when you have issues with
relationships with key figures in your
life it can actually frame your
understanding of the truth of religion
and I use my own personal experience and
when I suggested that might be the case
for him I'm telling you this Meek skinny
guy he like from my remember he stood up
he was crying he was shaking how dare
you emotional abuse we had to change the
subject we have to buy him food we had
to calm him down and to cut a long story
short when the other brother that was
with me is brother Sabor beautiful
brother
yeah absolutely Legend he spoke to the
brother's wife so not wife his mother
and his mother said yes his main issue
was with Father figures and then he
admitted that as well when he spoke to
his mother subsequently so we could have
been discussing Ai and Allah's names and
attributes until now but if you have a
more of intellectual and mature way of
The Da to understand that he's a human
being with a f it's like a vehicle if
all the variables are in place is going
to drive itself towards the truth but it
gets clouded and the only and it's the
only way it's not true that the only way
to unCloud the f is this rational
arguments it could be other things like
unpacking their trauma getting them to
stand in the possibility that the
meaning you're giving this trauma is not
the only meaning give the meaning that
Allah wants you to give it give the
meaning that the Sunnah wants you to
give it and that will make you transcend
your trauma and that trauma willon
become like a a negative filter to
actually bash religion or go against the
truth it could be they need to know who
Allah is who is your lord what are his
names and attributes how do you have a
relationship with him it could mean just
like engaging with the Quran it could be
so many different things for us to focus
on this abstract rational stuff to be
honest is is kind of like not in line
with the tradition yes it could be it's
needed and you may need to use it in
combination rational stuff rational
arguments with spirituality with you
know direct Quran even with telling
people about why Allah is worthy of
worship just explaining basic toed is
enough for them right that could be the
case you mean to use all of these things
in combination or just one I'm not
saying here is the algorithm that that
you need to use because to even frame it
that way you're assuming that the human
being is an AI machine it's not I'm
saying we have a toolkit this is what
the human being is if you're really
dedicated to the well-being and their
guidance you would now stand in the
possibility and think you know
what it's not just rational arguments is
going to win this person over maybe they
need something else and that really
opens Your da and it it gives you more
success because you may be successful
with a particular approach in the da
that you may just codify this is the way
to give da ABC rational arguments right
for example which we use and we agree
with but if you say that's that's your
main narrative and that's how you train
people what
about the thousands of people that
haven't become Muslim because you use
the wrong
approach because sometimes in da we like
to top ourself on the back like Well
Done Hamza you did this you trained this
you train thousands of people you got
many shahad whatever but someone who's
really sincere I think who has maybe
optimal sincerity should
ask what did I not do that I should have
done that actually prevented greater
success that's a different question bro
and was the that of the prophet of not
emotionally intelligent right 100% many
people think it's all rational and well
we see this in so many scenarios like
take for
example he became Muslim nominally but
he wanted to kill the prophet and he was
circumambulating the cabba so the person
notices this and I think he was holding
a dagger or he was basically wanting to
harm the prophet and the prophet said
you know what are you whispering to
yourself and basically reacted in a
particular way and the put his hand on
his heart and said ask Allah to forgive
you and then basically says you know
after that moment no was more beloved to
me than the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam why did he say ask Allah to
forgive
you I don't know but this is what I do
know about the Sunnah and this is how
how it links to down in a powerful way
the Sunnah is hikma so when you read
hikma in the Quran in many places it
would indicate Sunnah okay but in the
context of hikma what is so in the
context of the Sunnah and hikma what is
hikma so hikma because remember hi is so
important in da right because in chapter
16: 1 to5 Allah says call to the way of
your Lord with what hik with wisdom
Allah doesn't say
with just remember that in this verse
Allah doesn't say call to you know the
way of your Lord with with with no withk
now Allah makes a distinction between
hikma and as Allah says in Surah Yu we
we granted him wise judgment and and
this is how we reward the doers of good
so Allah is making a distinction between
wise judgment and El
because wise judgment or wisdom is the
application of in a context so when
Allah is saying give da with hikma we
need to have a goal okay what is your
goal in the da generally speaking is
making Allah's word the highest is
winning people's hearts over is you know
getting people to appreciate uncling
someone's F it's an Allah Centric goal a
goal that is pleasing to Allah not likes
shares not this kind of algorithm that
we've fallen into yeah we just ourselves
to to the algorithm or we become Dow
pimps for the algorithm right you know I
get someone who's famous and don't care
about his knowledge or his personality
let's do this it's all nonsense
right obviously there has a space and a
context we could we could unpack another
time but the point is it's not about
that it's about the most optimal thing
that is pleasing to Allah so if you're
dealing with a human being in the
context of individual da you want that
person to be awakened to the truth so
you want them to be awakened to the
truth right to their natural way this is
this is this is this is the natural way
of being it's their F it's within them
right Allah has placed it within them
you
know something has been created within
us to acknowledge Allah and to affirm
his existence and affirm his maximal
Perfection and so on and so forth so
that's the goal so you need to apply
yourm knowledge whatever knowledge you
have in the context now what's the
context the person their personality
social economic circumstances
psychological Contex whatever the case
may be so apply your in that Contex to
achieve that goal so here's the other
question how do you do that well you
have to know what the context is okay
well how do you do that you need to
learn to listen we don't have to listen
anymore you know people are like they
think they're listening no you're not
you're manufacturing a response that's
what you're doing right so usually when
you want to be seen as an active
listener we have a very inauthentic way
of listening we're like oh really ah
really really ah it's amazing you bought
that cabbage for 50 cents wow like you
don't care yeah like you know it's an
inauthentic way of being but it happens
because we live in that type of
culture what we need to learn to do is
to do something is called listen with
the intention to understand because the
Sunnah of giving doubt to individuals is
to individualize them so right I'm say
you came up to me said I'm an atheist
now it would be totally wrong for me to
take a schema of what an atheist is from
my limited experience is understanding
and superose it on you cuz I'm going to
miss you I'm going to I'm going to miss
the person because I'm going to think
you as an atheist must be Pro science
must be a Richard orins fan and if I
have that frame then and you're not of
that then I'm I'm not connecting with
you and that happened to me once
actually with a discussion with the
professor professor Ken Jes he's an
atheist and I was giving these deductive
arguments in a university debate at
Queen Mary and you know he said to him
at the end look I don't want this I want
to know about values I i' been taking
care of my disabled son for about 18
years or something I want to know what's
going on here talking about what Islam
has to offer in terms of values that
really caught me bro because I missed
him out in the in the conversation I'm
like abstract he's like a professor bro
and I'm talking about deductive
arguments this and the other fine I may
have come across as I won the debate I
did well but I lost him in the
conversation yeah you lost the heart of
course I lost the heart so because I
created a schema of what an atheist is
and I superimposed it on him and I
didn't with him on but if you now try
and remove that baggage historical
intellectual social experiential and
individualize them and see them for who
they are in their context and to do that
is to listen with the intention with
listen listen with the intention to
understand you'll get things from them
that you'll never get before that you'll
never have imagined like you'll
understand their context who they are as
humans when you say remove the baggage
are you talking about your own baggage
in my framing my framing of the person
yeah like for example you say Bali right
all right I have an experience of
bengalis their food their culture and so
on and so forth I could that's limited
to a certain
degree baggage that's baggage it doesn't
it's not necessarily negative baggage
but it's baggage that creates a frame
I'm framing you now in a particular way
so I may frame you with my perspective
of your culture or with my perspective
of who benulis are how they brought up
what the parent child relationship is
and so on and so forth and that really
ends up being just a frame it may help
in life I'm not saying he has his pros
and cons but when it comes to Da you
should try and suspend it as much as
possible and allow your commitment to
the well-being to come out and express
itself that I really want this person to
be guided I'm committed to the to the
goodness and the guidance and the way to
do that have to individualize them and
understand their context have to apply
in that context to achieve a particular
goal that's what that's what hikma is so
therefore I to listen with an intention
to understand and that is a hard thing
to do I'm not going to explain how to do
it here and I'm not even a master but I
do recommend one book it's called you're
not listening by Kate Murphy I read that
book and there was a part of that book
that I read it made me cry and which is
the easy thing but there was some really
powerful aspects in in that book and you
could tell she this woman is sincere
like I I wanted to find her on social
media I couldn't find her I wanted to
actually thank thank her and maybe even
give her da and talk to her because you
know this person has this a phenomenal
book if you really internalize the
concepts of that
book then you'll become a very very good
listener because you're really now about
okay I'm trying to understand the person
remember words are vehicles to meaning
we just attach ourselves to people's
words we don't attach ourselves to their
meaning and that's why when someone says
to me Hamza what do you mean by that you
won me over I love you you're my beloved
because my greatest fear is being
misunderstood yeah for for many reasons
yeah traumatic childhood trauma God
knows what it is but this one of my
issues yeah
so and that's why a good listener would
say okay what did you mean by that I wow
the guy's trying to actually trying to
understand me or the person is trying to
understand me so if you adopt that style
and we see that has come across in the
sun of the Prophet because you see hik
being applied in this way so take the
young man who came to
said I want to commit Zena and how did
the person respond he didn't say don't
you know it's har now that approach may
work for a particular person if you know
their context and you and you have a
good Allah Centric goal for them and you
apply your in that context to achieve
that goal but for the Youth how did the
person reply he basically say something
like what about your mother what about
your auntie what about your sister and
so on and so forth so he engaged with
him in the most optimal perfect way
understanding the person's context now
that may not be the case for everyone if
an older person came up to him and said
that maybe the prophet sallallah alaihi
was would had a different totally
different approach so the Sunnah you see
hik in the Sunnah throughout the Sunnah
even when when it came to like the you
know you know why didn't the prophet the
Hypocrites we have one narration where
the Prophet sallallah alai wasam said
basically then they know the qur are
going to say that oh Muhammad sallai
wasallam kills his companions right
that's not very wise thing to do he had
an Allah Centric goal he wants to make
Allah's word the highest he wants people
to be awakened to the truth of Islam
from a personal social and political
perspective as well you know that's not
a wise thing to do when you apply your
in that context you're not going to
achieve that goal do you see so this is
a good framing of what hikma is just to
repeat and you need this in the da have
an Allah Centric goal that is the ask
yourself what is the most pleasing thing
to Allah in this context don't talk what
is the most what is the Halal thing
because there are competition of
different halals if you're in the da you
should want the thing that's more
pleasing to Allah so ask what is the
most pleasing thing to Allah in that
particular da context it could be giving
da to an audience an individual or
whatever the case may be then apply
knowledge and if you don't have access
to access to it then learn it engage
with students of knowledge engage with
and so on and so forth take that
necessary knowledge which could be in
the form of principles as well apply it
to it that context that context could be
the person's psychology you know the the
emotional backdrop and so on and so
forth and apply in a way that would
achieve the goal and this is the kind of
hidden art of The Da and you see that as
well when people are speaking you know
you don't have a good goal for this
person you're using this person as an
instrument because you just you have
other goals in mind which may be fame or
it may be a good goal something times
you know people use people lamb to the
slaughter right okay I'm dealing with
one person but if I deal deal with them
in a particular way it may be the case
that I could access thousands of people
but that way is not optimal for him but
it's optimal for the other people I
don't know if that's the right thing to
do I kind of intuitively I have to think
about that but intuitively I would say
that's probably not the good thing to do
because generally speaking if you're
authentic with one person your
psychology comes across and it would win
over other people as well yeah do you
see my point I've been waing too long
yeah no no no worries it's all good H
it's amazing and imagine if like you
brought that person to Islam and it's
like on camera why would that not be
beneficial for the thousands of people
that yeah agree no actually I agree with
you I agree with you so you know if
you're always doing the right thing in
the right way and you have an Allah
Centric goal and you're applying in that
particular context to achieve that goal
there's going to be Baraka because
success is with the righteous Allah says
at the end of the day so if you're
always doing the right thing I think
that's that's where the Baraka lies the
daaka especially you know yeah and
getting more getting more out of less
right or you know 1 plus one is equal to
five that's what Baraka is isn't it yeah
you put two naturalistic things together
and something else happens something
Beyond it so I I usually say it's 1 plus
one is equal to five so holding on to
principles especially in the da is very
important because over the long term and
even the medium term you're going to see
those results maybe not even in your
lifetime maybe after your life but but
where it counts in the but sometimes we
shorts side we citize the da a bit
sometimes because of numbers and so on
and so forth
and we're very very kind of short to
medium term but I really believe if you
hold on to principles they end up
becoming your power they end up
basically I have this saying which is
you know if you had a choice between
power and principles and you chose power
over principles power will become your
weakness but if you chose principles
over power then principles will become
your strength and your success and you
see this in the daah because Allah makes
it clear that you know the victory the
success success is with the righteous
the final outcome is with those who are
God conscious so do the right thing and
over time it's going to help and that's
why sometimes you see a lot of noise in
the Dow yeah good noise don't get me
wrong but because we engage with people
on a onetoone level a lot like that
Lighthouse mentoring which is a project
of sap we give people one to one hours
like human time they have Shah
destructive doubts and so on and so
forth and we do it for free we've come
to the real realization doing it over a
couple of years now you know so many
people across the world we've been
mentoring we realize that even though
they have access to the answers
online and they know they may even know
they have access to the answers it
wasn't enough they needed that human
interaction and that is missing a lot
and I have a view about the algorithm
anyway the algorithm is designed to
basically contain you it's like a bubble
or it's like a echo chamber there's
migration in and out so we'll get good
results tap ourselves on the back and we
may think we're making a great impact
but me when I've been traveling the
world engaging with engaging with
activists engaging with leaders engaging
with du I've coming I'm come to the
realization now that it's somewhat in
the grand Cosmic scheme of things
containing
us it's smart the algorithm is smart
take my recent trip to Pakistan and this
how you think strategically yeah and I
could be wrong I stand in the
possibility I'm wrong yeah so in
Pakistan they have this whole issue
concerning liberal ISM secularism
feminism definitely but you know
significantly you have the
lq plus ideology right it's there now
it's at the universities gender study
departments there's funding in Pakistan
the Islamic Republic of Pakistan I I
just came back from Pakistan a few weeks
ago it was my fourth trip there as well
I was at the private universities lams
Baha IBA all of these places they even
have parties BR yeah Lums had and this
that and the other anyway put that to a
side for one moment the issue is this
ideology is there so I was speaking with
a really good I love them tobat great da
organization they felt or one of them
felt a leader felt that they broke the
back of the plus ideology and I was
thinking I don't know online maybe you
got that narrative people have accepted
your arguments maybe you want to debate
there's a lot of noise and you may have
some migration coming in meaning people
have changed their views from that
ideology to coming become more
practicing but when I traveled to
Pakistan I spoke to faculty I spoke to
students I engaged with questions I did
like a really good kind of he a personal
analysis but I think it was robust I
came to the conclusion this is that
statement was not completely accurate
because you had students saying that
many of their friends at college for
example either left the dean or joined
the UK plus narrative ideology
because of the Love Is Love manttra For
example yeah that rhetorical trap which
is nonsense yeah but and I spoke to the
faculty or spoke to leaders at
University they can't really challenge
this discourse because of the structures
that at play and so many different
things and I looked at that kind of
trajectory and even asked the leader of
that D organization if you continue what
you're doing right now and they continue
what they're doing right now and you
project five and 10 years ahead who's
going to win he said they're going to
win
so but the
focus on this particular issue generally
speaking not in in its entirety because
there is political activism going on
there's other things happening but
generally speaking a lot of the noise
was online and if we rely on that
algorithm it becomes an echo chamber
there may be some migration to make you
feel good about yourself but it's not
where the impact lies don't get me wrong
it's needed and necessary to create a
narrative but there are layers to this
game I was in laor you go into the
Bookshop bro and you see a book on the Q
Plus ideology not on our side against
our
narrative where is our books on this
issue where are the books on this issue
for our 12 year olds non-existent the
point is we have to see the da in a very
more strategic way and a way that is
more but I would even qu it's anas issue
there are levels ofas meaning
sometimes we get lost in our own noise
and we have to understand how we're
going to change these ideologies or
these challenges yes online is necessary
and it should not stop and we need it
but we can't just there's many layers to
this and we're missing out all the
layers because we've been stuck in this
Echo chamber we think we're getting
great results but if you look at it
holistically and I've seen this I went
to South Africa I went to um um Pakistan
many other places and I'm getting this
sense now it's almost deliberate
strategy to get the da to be very noisy
online to not think about the other
important necessary layers to make
effective change like writing of the
books at different levels of different
demographics different age groups in
different
languages doing actually Grassroots
interaction which is so significant
right dealing with politics in these
type of areas are making sure that
certain bills are not passed and so on
and so forth dealing with faculty
members training other leaders who are
dealing with these Grassroots issues
Empower them how to deal with these
issues going online is not going to do
that right they need to be empowered
significantly so they could actually now
have impact at universities create the
student groups make changes at the on
the faculty level challenge the new
departments that are emerging the gender
departments even it has to work on
academic level too so there are
different levels to this and when we
focus as du and we think you know we
give it we top ourselves on the back
it's actually naive and Pakistan was a
case study for me and I and I came to
this realization I was like we need to
reassess what impact means yeah and and
how we could change things yes and I
don't want to be misquoted the online
should maintain and it needs to happen
but I'm just trying to create an
awareness that there is many more levels
to this and if we're going to be
successful we have to start engaging
with those levels right now because as I
said to that senior the head of that Dow
organization if we continue what we're
doing right now and they continue what
we're doing right now we project five
and 10 years ahead who's winning they
are and that's where you have to now
start thinking about other things
training leaders training faculty
members creating different structures at
universities if you have the power to do
so dealing with the social political
aspects doing writing books Grassroots
as I mentioned from at different levels
of society it's hard work they're well
funded and they're doing it in this way
too it's not just online
you know I was in a hotel inord bro it's
called Avari Express I think that was
the name the UN I think paid for I've
never seen so many people in my life I
think the more the more I saw more
people in laor than I've seen in
anywhere in my life like physically face
to face they brought them all together
to do to do talks they were talking
about something concerning health or
medicine or AIDS or whatever the case
may be but the point is is back they
have this fun funed there Grassroots
they get you know uplifted and you know
they the ideologies promoted at
different levels not only online but
Grassroots schools structurally and
we're just focusing on one part of
it now don't get me wrong there are
other brothers and organizations that
are doing other things as well I'm not
trying to mframe the whole da but I'm
doing it s like this deliberately to get
people to think a little bit more
sincerely about but what really is
impact yeah and do I really want Allah's
word to be the high people to be
awakened to the truth of Islam and so on
and so forth or is it really about um
you know it's it's like a it's a it's
personal I want to get the best results
for myself as possible yeah you may be
sincere in that and you may get the
reward but is that the most optimal
thing to do because in the da you should
ask this question what is the most
pleasing thing to Allah to do in my
context we don't ask that question
because in many cases it could be stop
doing what you're doing it could be
support someone else from the back end
yeah because remember when you're in the
Dow and you're a
brand and that's who you are really
you're a brand aren't you yeah if you're
a brand and you don't have someone above
you I won't trust you I won't generally
speaking I won't trust you in the da I
trust you as a brother but in the da you
know I may not have that full one
relationship with you because there's
always going to be a conflict of
interest unless you falsely assume that
the your brand is the da if there's no
one above you like a student of
knowledge or a scholar or some to hold
your account then the da is such a
sensitive and important area that you
can't be trusted in certain things is it
because of ego yeah of course it could
be ego it could be that no one's
unveiling your blind spots you need to
have shter bro it's a key practice of
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasam
consultation you don't have it then how
can you even take the da seriously
unless you assume that you've got all
the experience and all the knowledge
needed necessary to to have a success if
that's the case then you're arrogant you
should be in the Dow anyway anyway do
you see my point you have a spiritual
disease there's a there's a greater
problem that's happening right so you
need to have you need to bounce ideas
and you need to understand that there's
going to be a conflict of interest
between your brand and your and the da
it's going to be a conflict of interest
because there's going to come a time
where you not saying something you're
not getting involved is the best thing
to do or you getting someone else to do
it do you see my point and that doesn't
always happen because people want credit
they do and that's why I'm really
impressed with Muhammad hijab Mah
recently when he was supposed to go to
the pbd podcast but he couldn't make it
and what does he do he gets Jake there
he gets Daniel there which you know
irrespective of other maybe issues that
people may have they were the best
people placed in America to do it
because the the brave actually some of
the bravest do that we know from the
perspective of what you need to do in a
debate with these type of people they
did a fantastic job right so that's a
good sign that you know hijab knows this
is not about me I can't do it I'm going
to get someone else to do it yeah yeah
because it could be the case that oh
let's
reschedule you know I'll come a week
later or trying to maneuver so you get
all the Limelight a hijab is no there
there's something bigger than me here
right and what is that is that the
vision is bigger than the organization
the organization is bigger than the
individual if you have an Allah Centric
Centric Vision it's pleasing to Allah
and that vision is going to take it to a
good place in the in the Hereafter then
you'll do anything to achieve that so
you now become subservient to the vision
but when you're a
brand
subconsciously you are the vision and
that is the most dangerous thing to
happen and that's where the conflict of
interest lies so you have to be able to
say look I'm not the best at doing this
job I don't care if I have a lot of
followers makes no difference if there
is someone better than me and he will
fulfill the objectives of The Da in a
better way then really you are
religiously spiritually ethically
theologically islamically which these
are all Syms in this context right
obliged obligated to put that person
there yeah right and that is going to be
a conflict with your brand because are
you going to say you you're always the
best person to this particular job how
can you even say such a thing don't get
me wrong there should be a space for you
to develop and improve for sure so it's
not there are this criteria but the
point is if you have good people above
you scholar students of knowledge they
can help you assess they can say
actually don't do this like I try even
when I tweet I share it with a scholar
or a student of knowledge not all the
time but if it's significant a tweet bro
and I've tweets I've written some tweets
that I haven't published it's like no
that's not good or this and you know
usually it makes me feel better writing
tweets I haven't published yet it's a
form of spilling yeah you know when you
see something so silly and you want to
like attack it in a way your ego's there
isn't it it's almost like you got a
hello your team is yeah yeah yeah and so
sometimes you want say to people shut
your mouth shut your mouth shut it just
want to go you know you get really angry
sometimes anyway so that's my The
Vicious personality coming out bro know
but anyway so some you get those you
express yourself and you you couch into
logical and spiritual language if you're
going to be a brand in the da you need
to have someone above you to unveil
those blind spots to help you to be more
Allah Centric Centric really for you to
have a vision for the da that is bigger
than you because your brand is not the
vision it's as a tool as a vehicle to
help facilitate where you see the world
for example my personal vision is a
world that is convinced of Islam so I
see the world in the future at some
point a world convinced of Islam yeah so
that's my see I see the world now I need
to be someone I need to be someone who's
optimally convinced of Islam and is able
to convince others of Islam and able to
lead an organization
to convince others of Islam in the most
optimal way and train others to be able
to convince other
people of Islam in the most optimal way
so that's my be this is who I must be
now that's a lot of stuff going on so
what must I do so my do is the daily
weekly monthly yearly and lifetime
things I have to do in order to achieve
the b in order to achieve the C and the
doe on a daily weekly monthly yearly
perspective is going to be actions that
I can demonstrate that were necessarily
link to the be meaning I need to be
optimally convinced of Islam I need to
be able to convince others of Islam in
an optimal way I need to be able to lead
an organization that convinces others of
Islam in the most optimal way I need to
be be able to lead the organization that
trains other people that facilitates and
empowers them in order for them to
convince others in the most optimal way
so that requires a lot of stuff on a
daily weekly monthly my physicality for
longevity and presence my my secular
studies this that the other my
spirituality in terms of my is it on
point in the morning evening the duas in
the morning the evening the T prayer the
Quran all of this stuff so all of these
things at different in different domains
of my life or spheres of my life on a
daily weekly monthly yearly perspective
has to be linked in some way to achieve
the be and once I be that person then I
could achieve the sea am I the only
person that's going to achieve that sea
no no but every drop raises the ocean
I'm I'm facilitating that sea so now it
reframes my way of being in the da
everything is linked to where I see how
I see the world where I see the world in
the future a world convinced of Islam
and I need to be someone like I just
discussed and I need to do certain
things on a weekly daily weekly monthly
yearly perspective to achieve that
okay and therefore if I'm always about
the vision then it could be be the case
that I don't do certain things or I
close the
organization cuz if if hopefully and
obviously I don't want Allah to test me
with my words but if it came to the
point that closing down sapience
Institute was the best to achieve the
vision best thing to achieve the vision
I'll do it straight
away we here we're the organization is a
vehicle for the vision right if it's not
needed anymore or it's actually not not
good for the vision or you closing down
for any reason social political context
who knows closing it down is good for
the
vision then you should do it do you see
my point or if it means leaving the
organization is good for the vision and
getting someone better to lead the
organization or you engaging with other
domains uh of activity in the da and if
that's better for the vision then so be
it if it means leading in the front more
now and that's better for the vision you
should do it if it means taking a step
back and leading from the back more then
you should do it because the whole thing
is about your vision because your vision
what is your vision it has to be Allah
Centric and Centric it's the most
pleasing thing to Allah and it's the the
vehicle that's going to take you to
Jenna so if that is the case then really
you're just one of those Vehicles right
and sometimes you could be in the front
in the middle in the back some you have
to stay silent sometimes you have to not
do anything sometimes you have to do
more who knows but in your context if if
you are Vision Centric Allah Centric ARA
Centric then thing the things that we
the problems that we have in the da
would be easily resolved easily resolved
because a lot of us we just lack that
bigger Vision the vision is just the
brand but anyway there's so much more to
talk about concerning this because a lot
of this really fundamentally is the the
state of our heart spiritual heart we
may have a bit of arrogance a bit of bit
of ostentation a bit of hassad blame
with the jealousy a bit of k a bit of
arrogance vanity
so you know self amazement and those
things we need to deal with we're all on
different levels and you know I think I
was saying to um think one of the kids
yesterday I was like you know true men
Elevate other
men and that's very important and
especially in the da a true a true man
elevates other men right because if you
see someone who's in the da that
supposed to be doing things for Allah's
sake but they now become the other the
enemy the compet
and you treat them in a way that doesn't
optimize them then really this is not a
really good characteristic to have
because we need to elevate each other
and that s doesn't happen but it would
happen if you have an Allah Centric
vision and AK Centric Vision you have a
lofty Vision yeah and the case study
that we gave an example of the pbd
podcast that was a really good example
to show that look you have a so if it's
about Allah it's about having that
particular vision for the da wanting
Allah's word to be the highest people
giving people the opportunity to embrace
his true truth and this beautiful Dean
then if you can't do it then you get
someone else who can not about yeah you
see the point but how do you step the
ego to the
side well first you have to develop a
vision because once you do that it
reframes you a lot then you you still
may have an ego but you have the ability
to understand
okay I now know what is the best thing
to do right I I the the ideal scenario
is I want Allah's pleasure the optimal
pleasure of Allah the thing that's most
pleasing to Allah and what I want to
achieve is the thing that's going to
take me to Jen the highest level of Jen
the prophet if you're the prophet said
if you're going to ask for J ask for fos
that's for the highest level so your
your vision should be connected to that
Allah's pleasure and
fos so if that's the case then you can
always ask your question now because
this is linked to your AA now right this
is about your
eternity and it's about meaning what's
more meaningful as well if it's your ego
it's meaningless anyway on the day of
judgment it's never way weigh anything
so now you're in this state of like I
know what the best thing to do is yes my
ego is saying that I should do it this
that and the other or whatever but
because you have that Vision it's
driving you now you see because you're
motivated by your AA because every
Muslim wants to go to paradise even if
they have an ego right that's one way of
dealing with it another way of dealing
with it you have to be dealing with your
ego on a daily basis anyway what's the
Hope Salah one of the kind of the
impactful things of the the daily prayer
is to make you as humble as possible
you're putting your head on the floor
you're saying Allah is the highest you
you're basically
nothing so improving your Salah
increasing your your
Salah lengthening your your s your your
prostrations doing in the morning of the
evening the duas in the morning of the
evening the recitation of the Quran the
of the Quran Allah says do they do do
they not ponder over the Quran or their
locks on their hearts you can mirror
this meaning the more you do the more
your heart becomes unlocked to receive
Allah's guidance and mercy be around
with people who are sincere what do you
mean there so the the more pondering you
do over the Quran ping yeah the more
your heart's going to become unlocked
you can receive Allah's guidance and
mercy be around Pious people egoless
people or people who are humble who are
struggling with themselves because if
you're with four people who are stupid
you're going to be the fifth stupid
person if you're going to be four people
who are Pious you may be the the fifth
if you have four people who have who
have you know um you know there's a
sense of M the person is is a sincere
person and if you have four you're going
to be as well you're going to be more
likely to be sincere so your environment
is very important as well because it it
it formulates you it shapes you and we
know this from social psychology we know
this in the Quran and the Sunnah so
there are there are a lot of tools that
you use spiritually and otherwise that
actually get you to be more uh that
deals with your your ego and a lot of
the problems with the ego is you need to
realize who Allah is Al gazali in his he
wrote I forgot what volume it was but it
was about and and about arrogance and
vanity he's got about three pages in
that volume the probably the most
well-written pages I have ever read on
the topic and if you read them aloud
you'll end up crying in a few paragraphs
and just by reading it and trying to
understand it it will make you humble
the way Al gazali took from the Quran
how the the human being like you know
when Allah says there was a time that
you weren even mentioned you were
nothing and Al gazali argues what is
more humiliating that non-existence
itself that's the the most debased thing
you could be so he starts with that he
starts about who are you and when you
die you're going to be you're just feces
anyway and he I don't want to spoil it
for you but you read those couple those
those few to read them read it I read it
loud it helps you just reading it
because the way he was able to take the
quranic narrative and just show that you
are actually who the hell are you who do
you think you are like you know focusing
about your Origins where did you come
from you
are and you were a a a a a a a small
piece of drop of fluid from a despised
fluid and now you think you're somebody
yeah you know and if you and remember a
lot of the spiritual stuff in Islam
people think you need to do spiritual
activity a lot of it is by the way a lot
of is who you who you know who is Allah
because once you focus on Allah's names
and attribut you know who Allah really
is it just it frames you in the correct
way this is cognitive spiritual
reframing by understanding who Allah is
Allah is the greatest you're not Allah
is he is the absolutely independent
everything depends on him so you realize
my so-call successes my so-call
abilities they're not intrinsic to me
how can they be because in order for me
to be here today with the so-called
successes even in the doubt that I have
today there were almost an infinite
number of variables that were outside of
my control that were necessary in order
for me to achieve what I achieve but
they were outside of my
control but yet all of those things
including myself are all dependent on
Allah subhana wa tala so how can you
even be arrogant because there are
necessary things in your life socially
spiritually familywise economically
systemic whatever that were in place
that were necessary for you to achieve
what you're achieving right now and you
have zero control you had zero control
over those things but all of those
things were ultimately controlled by and
dependent on Allah subhah wa taala so
how can you even be
arrogant so that so that even knowing
who Allah is that solves the equation
and there's more to say about this but
that's something that's very important
because some people think
oh you know if I do more thck i' be less
arrogant which could be true you know
everything has a Polish and the Polish
of the heart is the thck of Allah
subhana wa tala for sure but a lot of it
stems from understanding who you are who
Allah is and how you should relate to
him once you fix those things and you
have knowledge of Allah his names and
attributes and really knowledge of
yourself in the truest sense then a lot
of these other these spiritual diseases
actually diminish over time but another
time we could talk about that another
time another place all right bro it's
it's honestly been real man I've just
waffled you've said nothing I've said
everything yeah
[Laughter]
you or waffled which one was
it what was the book called
again yeah so Al Al gazali's book is
basically his treatment
on arrogance and so it's one of the
volumes of his of his Revival of
religious of religious Sciences it has
been translated you could purchase it in
in any book in most Islamic book stores
I mean there is C certain pages of that
book that just phenomenal we'll link it
in the description inshah all
right that being said with that being
said